l'eau une des grandes richesses du
Québec dans la naudière Saint-Donat peut
compter sur une vingtaine de lacs Benoît
Barbeau y a grandi
l'ingénieur se spécialise en traitement
des eaux pour les citoyens à prendre
cette nouvelle c'est certain que c'est
stressant Saint-Donat a été informé
d'une possible contamination de sa nappe
phréatique où elle puisse nous les pfas
des polluants dit éternels parce qu'il
subsiste dans l'environnement sont en
cause on parle des effets sur le fœtus
au niveau de la croissance fœtale des
changements au niveau des niveaux
circulants de cholestérol certains
cancers comme le cancer du rein les
données sont pas assez claires pour
déterminer s'il y a une concentration à
partir de laquelle on commence à avoir
des effets néfastes des chercheurs de
l'Université de Montréal ont
échantillonné l'eau potable de 376
municipalités
99% des échantillons contenait des pfas
deux villes affichent des niveaux plus
critiques Val d'Or et Saint Donat
si j'avais la famille à Saint-Donat ou à
Val-d'Or je recommanderais au moins
d'acier d'avoir un traitement
supplémentaire à la maison et de faire
pression pour qu'il y ait quelque chose
qui se fasse parce que l'eau serait un
peu inquiète au Québec il n'y a pas de
norme pour les PHAs dans l'eau potable
Santé Canada à proposer un nouveau seuil
fixé à 30 nanogrammes par litre les
résultats de Saint-Donat dépasseraient
de plus du double cette proposition avec
des échantillons de 68 à 82 nanogrammes
par litre
j'avais déjà réduit ma consommation
d'eau parce qu'il y avait un avis de
santé publique sur la présence de
manganèse j'ai un péché filtrant que
j'utilisais que j'utilise à Val d'Or les
échantillons prélevés varient de 35 à
171 nanogrammes par litre c'est presque
6 fois la proposition de l'Agence
canadienne
la santé publique ne veut pas se
prononcer et la refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue le ministère de
l'Environnement l'a fait moi je boirais
ça m'inquiète pas les élus de
Saint-Donat avait déjà planifié de
changer la source d'eau et à la suite
des questions de Radio-Canada Valdor a
condamné un de ces deux puits et la
convoqué les médias lundi matin
alors mon nom on sait que c'est
polluants sont présents dans notre eau
mais on ne sait pas comment ils arrivent
là ouais on fait les scientifiques dans
le cas de Saint-Donat ont certaines
hypothèses lorsqu'ils analysent la
signature chimique des échantillons
d'eau il voit des composés qui
s'apparentent à ceux de mousse pour
éteindre des incendies or c'est connu et
ses documentés qui a des zones des lieux
plus concentrés en pfas où on a utilisé
ces mousses et à Saint-Donat l'ancien
site d'enfouissement a été le lieu pour
éteindre ces incendies bien sûr c'est
une hypothèse faudrait le valider par
des études hydrogéologiques à Val-d'Or
bien là on a aucune idée on cherche à
comprendre évidemment et je souligne
également Claudine qui a deux autres
villes au Québec qui excèdent la
proposition actuelle ou la proposition à
venir de Santé Canada c'est cinq Sicile
de Milton en Estrie également
Sainte-Adèle dans les Laurentides les
deux villes sont au courant et les deux
villes se sont dites préoccupés par dans
cette situation et ce n'est pas un
problème qu'au Québec un peu partout
dans le monde on commence à s'inquiéter
de ces polluants oui et on veut
documenter cette contamination
d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours il y a
17 médias européens qui ont publié une
vaste enquête pour cibler des lieux des
ondes plus critiques et partout sur la
planète il y a également une tendance à
réduire les seuils les recommandations
de contamination dans l'eau potable ça
va de la moins stricte qui est l'OMS
jusqu'à la plus stricte et qui est
l'agence américaine de protection de
l'environnement et d'ailleurs ça fait un
émoi cette proposition parce que c'est à
des niveaux de détection seulement c'est
si bas que si ça devenait une
recommandation et bien la majorité des
villes québécoises excéderaient le seuil
américain merci beaucoup Maud et on
regarde votre reportage complet jeudi à
l'émission Enquête bonne soirée au
revoir